hi my name is malia and i'm six years
old and today i'm going to have two
chefs compete to make my dream dish
i'm getting some so cold
hi malia hi i'm alex nice to meet you
everybody
hi maria marie
nice to meet you nice to meet you rolex
returns i am so excited to
not only be back for i draw you cook but
to cook alongside my favorite rie have
you ever built a snowman before yes you
have sam what do you think snowman would
eat i think you would eat a snow sushi a
pinecone
and wild berries and magic snow
i
i wasn't expecting this
so do you want to go ahead and draw us
this
magical snowman feast this is the plate
this is like the salad
so this is the big a fish
fish so we're really going for it
so do you like eating sushi uh yeah but
every time when i asked to eat sushi my
mom and dad say no you're not gonna eat
you're just gonna waste it and they say
no i'm really gonna eat it and they
never listen she said she loved sushi it
could be risky because sometimes kids
say they like it but they don't what is
your favorite part of the sushi the rice
i'm like a rice girl
girl me too
what kind of fish do you like i don't
know what kind of fish i would like but
i do love fish she says she likes it but
do i trust her
no and then the outside would be dark
green because it's seaweed right yeah
you like um sweet things or savory
things or
it's a pine cone pine pond pine are not
food so i can make whatever i want so
what are you drawing now
the berries the berries
okay do you like berries
uh not really but this this is gonna
have berries so snowman eats berries but
she doesn't like berries it's pretty
confusing do you like strawberries no no
not really so grapes are only
fruits you like yeah fleshing i'm gonna
draw it's a magic snow it has sparkles
on it i've done a lot of i draw you cook
but i don't want to be too confident i
have learned to stay pretty true to the
drawing itself do you think riya and i
can build this dish for you
yes yes thank you for believing in us
and we will see you later
time to snow
[Music]
for my snowman dish i'll be making sweet
and savory snow scape i'm going to start
with two beds of lettuce topped with
shrimp temperature rolls i'm going to
build pine cones with pretzel loads in
center and covered with peanut butter
and hazelnut spread for the wild berries
i'm going to coat the grapes in white
chocolate finally for the magic snow i'd
be making snowball cookies with pop
blocks topped with spawn sugar here is
my snow plan for the snow sushi i'm
going to be making a base of a white
chocolate seaweed and topping it with a
thai mango coconut sticky rice sushi for
the pine cone i'm going to be making a
chocolate peanut butter center and i'm
going to adorn it with chocolate peanut
butter covered rice cereal and i'm going
to dust it with a powdered sugared snow
for the wild forest berries i'm going to
frost grapes by double coating them in
sugar and for the magic snow i'm going
to be making a vanilla ice cream
snowball covered in coconut and
sprinkles
so really what are you going to do first
i'm making sushi it has to be my
strategy like give kids what they want
i'm more like i give them the picture
and yeah
that's the style
i'm not giving her sushi rice i don't
even know how to make sushi rice i have
quarter cup of vinegar and one
tablespoon spoon
one tablespoon of sugar and quarter
teaspoon of salt so i have rice ready
and i'm going to mix this vinegar
little by little although these were
forest berries
she doesn't seem to like berries very
much so i just put half a cup of water
and half a cup of sugar i'm gonna
dissolve this sugar down and then i'm
gonna throw the grapes into this so
it'll make a candy sugar coating have
you made it before
no okay now that they're all like coated
in this sugar water mixture i am going
to space them out onto this tray so now
i'm just gonna set these behind me and
leave them to dry they should take like
about an hour which is again why i did
it first so i'm going to make a snowball
cookie i'm going to use pop rocks this
is my secret
not again
last season i used pop rocks for
linden's dish what are those noises in
my head
stop it i love to have reactions so much
i kind of want to see other kids how
they react when they eat pop rocks so
i'm going to process two cups of walnuts
mix sugar
flour
vanilla softened butter and mix well so
for my sushi i'm actually going to be
making
not sushi because i just don't believe
her
instead i'm going to make one of my
favorite desserts and it's mango coconut
sticky rice i'm going to start with the
rice now i'm oh opening this can of
coconut milk which this can opener is
giving me a little bit of a hard time
something's wrong here i'm just gonna
dump this out in here
my secret weapon in this competition
candy melt
food coloring
the rice is so blue yeah i'm gonna dye
this rice blue oh yeah that is beautiful
i'm gonna put a little bit of sugar in
here cause this rice is gonna be sweet
burning a little but it looks really
good i'm also going to mix in some
shredded coconut she is
using coconut coconut is a tricky
ingredient for a kid it does look kind
of like snow it's like a cartoon snow
maybe
so it's a right texture so i'm going to
form this into a snowball bake this uh 3
25 20 to 30 minutes i am going to start
cutting this mango it's gonna be a
little bit trickier than i thought to
cut this mango like fish but i only need
two pieces this could kind of look like
a fish
right if you screenshots
i'm going to make pinecones and i'm
going to use peanut butter nutella
powder sugar and
i'm doing like the exact same thing oh
my god
great mind think alike clearly great
minds google alike so the battle of the
cone
of pond the ultimate i know
like alex only one pine cone wins we'll
see
okay so i'm just melting some milk
chocolate i mean that's how you make
muddy buddies i'm going to skip that
part really i thought you were the
dessert snob
yeah you're not making your money
buddies from scratch
how would your teachers feel i don't
think kids or adults can tell the
difference if it's handmade or stubble
muddy body at least i'm making the
scales of the pine cone from scratch so
maybe that's my advantage i'm going to
start a culinary school where i teach
only muddy how to make muddy buddies so
i melted this chocolate down and now i'm
adding some peanut butter some butter
then i'm gonna add
the cereal to this it looks
a little weird
but i'm gonna go with it major our 3 4
cup of peanut butter 1 3 cup of nutella
softened butter and powdered sugar so i
have this mixture ready it's moldable so
i use pretzel rod as a spine so this
mixture is very soft so you can just
stick the muddy body into this mixture
that's the thing like i need them to
stay in their chex shape so it's a
little hard stirring this because the
chocolate is so thick and i don't want
to break them i don't remember it being
this hard to make muddy buddies and i
need the cereal to stay whole for the
scales of the pinecones now i'm going to
put this powdered sugar just eyeball in
it i think maybe eyeballing it's not a
good idea did you not learn to eyeball
encounter in school riya is almost done
with putting her scales on the pinecone
and i haven't even finished mixing this
cereal together so maybe it was actually
a bad call to do this by scratch i
like my first fine point i'm happy what
i did yeah it's cute
i'm just digging through this bowl and
trying to find like whole checks and
coating them a little extra in this
powdered sugar by looks of how many i
need this is going to take
i'm having flashbacks to that time that
i sorted fruity pebbles by hand this was
the worst idea i've ever had why do i
keep doing this to myself this is very
soothing like it's fun it's like a
puzzle this isn't that soothing to me
so mine's done so i'm going to put in a
refrigerator
bye
bye it actually might be an advantage
that she's finished hers first because i
got to watch her and now i'm gonna try
to improve upon it so i'm gonna make my
pinecone base
i'm actually gonna measure this time
because i don't want to mess it up just
trying to shape my pinecones
based on the memories i had the pen
cones
i used to throw you
you know i think the extra effort was
pretty worth it they're looking like
pine cones to me like you would find
them out in the dirt
so i'm just going to pop this in the
fridge now just because it's a little
fragile and i want it to set next i'm
going to move on to shrimp tempura i
want to make it no curl up tempura
butter one cup of cake flour large egg
and ice water i'm using ice water so
tempura gets super crispy you have to
mix egg and water first
and then adding flour so it doesn't
create a lot of gluten my oil is right
temperature deep shrimp
frying a 350 sprinkle butter so it kind
of has a good coating
okay so my shrimp is ready
and i'm gonna drain some oil
this one looks good
so we got some candy melts and i am
going to be melting these down to make
my green seaweed base because again i'm
not doing
actual sushi in all my years of taking
care of kids and being on this show
i know one thing you can't really go
wrong with sweet i'm gonna add a little
bit of coconut oil i've learned but if
i'm gonna add some food coloring that
needs a little fat so it won't seize up
so i've got my candy melt green and my
white chocolate green well it's not
really the green that i wanted but it's
fine just trying to stay true to her
drawing all right i'm done piping the
seaweed looks all right i'm gonna go
with it
i have
sushi
nori i'm gonna put rice have you made a
lot of sushi before now i'm trained
classical french cuisine oh i thought
you could say between
sushi
i was like what so i chop it up shrimp
tempura so every bite has the shrimp
and
roll it
[Music]
[Music]
it's a big sushi roll
[Music]
you know a lot of people think it's like
japan sushi right like if you think
about japanese food it's sushi but we
don't eat sushi every day like sushi is
expensive like yeah it's exciting so
it's like
eat it every day yeah so one done
i'm gonna make another one with this
secret weapon number two colored nori
wrap this with plastic so it holds the
shape until i use it and then you just
cut it
so this rice is actually pretty sticky
so it's able to kind of mold into its
shape now it's kind of the trickier part
just because i don't know how this is
gonna
i just
it's kind lay cute it kind of looks like
fish
kind of old fish but fish nonetheless
so now i'm just gonna put this little
guy onto my seaweed oh my god it's so
cute i love it and it's looking spot on
to her drawing sushi is
done for wild berry i'm going to melt
white chocolate and
dip grapes in it i look at my chocolate
covered grapes and i look at her picture
color is completely different so i've
decided to improvise with easy fix i'm
going to sprinkle some blue and a purple
sugar sprinkles so now that my sugar
water berries have set i'm just gonna
roll these in sugar so they kind of get
like a frosted effect as if grapes
weren't sweet enough right why not dip
them in sugar twice final stretch final
stretch i'm
sorry so last thing i'm going to do i'm
going to spin some sugar for magic snow
get some fancy snow make it fun
grand very own
one cup of sugar and one cup of corn
syrup well clearly you didn't learn
eyeballing for me which is what i'm
gonna do for my magic snow eyeballing
this coconut and for the glitter i guess
i'll just do some sprinkles okay i have
some cookie
and i'm gonna coat with powdered sugar
i'm just rolling my ball of ice cream in
this coconut and the sprinkles so it
will kind of look like a snowball i got
this
look like what did you put down a tree
last episode when i compete against
alvin he was using slave play and
tj was over the moon
wow this looks cool
i realized plate is also important
factor to win all right this has gone
too far if you win because of your
freaking plate it's just a play alex
yeah you said that now
as if this competition isn't hard enough
already now we gotta bring plates into
it i'll be back
so i put some powdered sugar on top of
my wood plate so it looked like a
winterland start with this snowball
cookie
she really went for looking for play huh
so this is my wild berry so sugar looks
shiny and beautiful
oh that's so cute it's like a snowflake
yes wow we've really upped our game on
this competition so i've added my sushi
my pinecones and my frosted grapes to
the plate i'm actually really happy with
this plate choice it's different from
the tree it still looks like ice
it's making some
progress and when you pull it it's whole
in a air and it makes strings when i'm
doing this i don't know when to stop i'm
going to top with pop rocks very
interesting choice
lettuce hey it's
iceberg lettuce
and oh my sushi oh my god it looks
really good do you want to eat it no but
yeah
okay now i'm just gonna put my snow my
magic snow on the plate and that's the
pine pond that's so cute
alright i guess it's
snow time
show time
i think my dish stands out gray
the pine pinecones looks cute
i have sushi that malia said she likes
the snowballs look like magical and wild
berries look exactly like her drawing my
plate looks snow
good the snow sushi is vibrant and
colorful the pine cones are rustic and
straight outta nature the frosted
berries are glistening and the snowball
is so good i could throw it i can't wait
for melia to try it
[Music]
bring me my snowman feast
awesome
awesome's good it looks a lot like my
drawing okay phew she thinks it looks
like her drawing that's big i don't know
what this is made of i think it's made
out of cheese and
chocolate she's in for a surprise
[Music]
it doesn't really taste that good
because of the mango i don't really like
mangoes this mango is a no-go the rice
tastes good but just not the mangoes
that's what tastes really good
[Music]
she didn't hold back with the pine cones
so seems like a good sign
[Music]
hey
there are pretzels in this
i like it
it tastes really really good wild
berries are a win this was like the
easiest thing on the planet
wait a minute this is actually ice cream
i love it it's really really good you
can't go wrong with ice cream kids loves
ice cream how i forget about that
this is chocolate how did they do that
it tastes good i think i may have been
able to redeem myself from the mango
incident
what
tweezers
why don't i need tweezers
really lovely
the first reaction is amazing it looks
just like my picture how about that i'm
gonna try the sushi first i never tried
to see
out of nowhere she said she never had a
sushi and my heart is pounding
[Music]
nothing is really good it's real sushi
with shrimp in it and i really love it
i'm in trouble
[Music]
really good
it tastes amazing
[Music]
she tried pop rocks my expectation was
so high it's a little bit disappointing
nice try really your secret weapon
didn't work this time
the one i like the best is the sushi i'm
so happy i took the risk the one that i
don't really like is this i don't like
vanilla cookies i like chocolate chip
cookies going into judging i'm not
really sure how this is going to go i
mean she didn't like the mango but she
also didn't like read cookies so
we'll see
hi malia hi
how are you doing again
i had a really fun snow day
so malia which one did you like better
the magic snow ball ice cream one or
snow shrimp sushi snow shrimp yes
that was mine
i can't say i'm surprised
cesarie this is your trophy thank you so
much
i don't watch sports at all but i feel
like i'm the lebron james of i draw you
cook
is it accurate she gave the kid the
sushi maybe i should have listened to
the kids this is a lesson in trust
we know sushi
[Music]
rolex forever
you